the first 5g pilots are launching in the
UK promising everything from smart
cities to hologram calls yet the rush to
build the superfast wireless network
comes with a risk because the best
technology comes from Chinese
manufacturers such as hawawa and ZTE
raising the fear that China's government
will gain ground level access to even
control of the UK's critical data
infrastructure prompting a former
security minister to urge the government
to act we've really got to grasp this
we've got to see there's a risk yes we
want 5g but goodness sake we need to do
all of these things to make sure it's
not putting us all at risk what I would
do is set up a small unit in the Cabinet
Office who'd be responsible to the
National Security Advisor and then on
through to the prime minister for coming
up with proposals that would ameliorate
the risk of using this Chinese equipment
a call which comes against their
backdrop of rising tensions in April
this year GCHQ x' national cybersecurity
center warned ZTE could pose a national
security risk in july the uk's hawawa
cybersecurity evaluation center a group
set up by the government to monitor the
chinese firm announced that it had only
limited assurance that hawaii posed no
threat to national security
finally in August the Australian
Government took the step of banning
hawawa and said te from supplying
technology for its 5g network in a
statement hawawa
expressed frustration at the move
calling the decision politically
motivated not the result of a fact-based
transparent or equitable decision-making
process there is no fundamental
difference between 5g and 4G network
architecture but the former director of
GCHQ says that safety and security are
based on trust which at the moment is in
short supply we do need to find a way of
scrutinizing what is being installed in
our networks and how it is
ever seen and how it's been controlled
and how it's being upgraded in the
future because very often this is about
the next generation and we have to find
a more effective way of doing that at
scale in the West VT which continues to
use huawei products told Sky News that
it will apply stringent security
measures and controls to 5g leaving the
next generation of mobile communication
vulnerable from it's very inception role
amantha Sky News